- Oh God.
(audience laughing)
I'd like to explain.
It's...
Sadly, I'd like to say
the one with the tiny hat
which by the way was
from Barbie western wear.
I'd love to say it was
a joke or a character.
It wasn't.
I was told if I, when I got to LA
because I'd only done plays in New York.
And I met with...
I finally was like, I'm
getting a commercial agent.
They're like, I wasn't but I
was going to meet with someone.
And he said if you
wanna work in this town,
you've gotta do character shots.
And I was like, oh I think
those make me uncomfortable.
I said is that when someone's
like in a cop jacket
and then the next thing
they're the burglar.
And I was like, I don't, I
don't think I wanna do that.
And he's like, well then
you don't wanna work
and you can't work with me.
But I didn't know it
was supposed to be like
things you may get cast as.
Like a waitress or a cop.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I went to do that headshot
and I was like, this is Carol.
She works at a Bonds.
(audience laughs)
She says what you can't
see is under the picture
I'm holding a plastic tray
with Velveeta slices on it.
(audience laughs)
And I had a whole thing.
I was like, she works in a grocery store
at the end of an aisle.
And she passes out cheese samples.
- [Kelly] She's about
to whip up some Rotel.
- And I brought this back to my agent.
And he was like, what the hell is this?
(audience laughs)
He's like, what does this mean to anyone?
I'm like, I don't know.
I said I didn't wanna do it.
- But it stands out.
It stands out.
- Unfortunately, sure did.
No one ever calls me in on that.
Because I look crazy.
- Their loss.
- That's what I say.